thank you so much thank you so much for
inviting me very happy to be here how
are you guys doing how you get can you
guys hear me well alright alright so
let's get started today we're going to
be talking about how to you know be a
painter without not knowing much about
painting and let's see at the end of the
top my goal is that you guys have a
little bit of idea how to go back home
and try it yourself and experiment with
it so before we get into the details
just to briefly introduce myself again
my name premier Chaudhary these are the
you know the social media handles that
you can reach out to me Amalie data
scientists at data science comm most
recently I've been focusing on how to
you know be basically the effective ways
of optimizing and evaluating machine
learning algorithms with modern
interpretation is another example of it
I'll talk about that also in a bit but
the whole idea is that how can we make
machine learning get applied to to solve
real world problems in a more effective
manner so today's talk the agenda will
be to make sure everybody's on the same
page we're going to be doing a recap on
the analytical workflow we briefly make
sure I'll make sure that everybody's on
the same page with respect to
correlational convolutional neural
networks because I'm guessing not
everybody does deep learning or image
segmentation or classification on a day
to day basis introduce principal oh not
sure if everybody knows about Levy and
Spock magic so these are some recent
projects that have come along quite
interesting briefly explain the style
transfer algorithm and then how you know
a small experiment that I did to scale
the the parameter tuning for style style
transfer algorithm using spark intensive
slope and then to the end
we get to be Q&A
so see second point okay so I'm sure
most of you guys are familiar with the
you know the typical analytical workflow
right so we start with first defining
some hypothesis of a use case that we
are trying to solve then we handle the
data which means we transform the data
do some ETL operation on it and then the
other aspect of it is engineering and
then feature selection then we build a
model if we want to operationalize this
we deploy it in some form and then we
get to the aspect of testing and
monitoring I have two other boxes on the
top but for today's topic not be
focusing on that but that's more related
to how do we effectively evaluate and
interpret models so for today's topic
since we're talking about deep learning
the most important aspect when we look
at deep learning is that we don't want
to create these features with hands this
becomes small makes more sense in case
when we are handling text and images
because the amount of feature that we
could think of is just exponential there
is no end to it and then the other
problem is the a lot of causal relation
that is there across different feature
sets a lot of nonlinear relationship
which we may or may not have domain
knowledge about it to formulate it
ourselves so we look for look towards
deep learning that okay can we have a
box where we give this huge feature set
and it's determined somehow it
determines what those nonlinear
relationships are and gives us a result
which is satisfactory so that's what
I've kind of marketers green here
because that's what we'll be focusing
into this talk so before we get to the
topic the universe is changing right
deep learning is becoming more and more
prominent into real life use cases so
I'm sure everybody kind of knows that
the whole algorithm of the basic
algorithm has been around since 1950s if
I recall correctly and if you go and
check back the like you know the history
graph of deep learning it's
inside Rico and there is always like a
peek because there's a huge G mind and
people realize oh god they can't make it
work effectively then it goes down and
then there's like you know it's a it's a
code so now we are in the space where we
are on the peak again because now it
seems people are able to apply to solve
real world problems and why that is
happening is because the amount of data
that we are collecting is is increased
more heterogeneous devices are
interconnected which means they're
generating more and more data which is
very useful for deriving this nonlinear
relationship hence solving the real
world problem in an effective manner the
other one is that people are getting
like you know just the the manual
feature creation is getting really
tiresome there is more than one use case
to solve at one point in time and so
we're looking through systems which
could help us automate this this aspect
of machine learning or predictive
modeling and then the most important
aspect is the computation resources
getting cheaper so like you know five
years back maybe if we had access to a
GPU box it was like oh great like you
know we have access to GPU box but now
CPUs the Rams are getting cheaper like
you know it's very easy to get access to
like huge clusters becoming easy to get
access to GPU clusters so things are
things are becoming more it so like the
the resources of much easily available
for us to experiment and derive a make
deep learning models work so with that
let's quickly define what we mean by
deep learning so deep learning is an
artificial neural network it's a subset
of that basically we say deep because
it's more than two layers that is part
of the neural network that is being
created we define hierarchic hierarchy
of hierarchy of multiple layers for
nonlinear processing unit for feature
extraction and transformation basically
it's a collection of simple trainable
mathematical functions of this nonlinear
relationship that we are trying to
articulate a capture is basically
derived out of simple linear equations
which are overlapped in multiple
different
it to understand what other latent
interaction is there that we as humans
are not able to capture and and then
like as we mentioned in the last slide
the the adoption is is extended is
continuously or exponentially
accelerated especially around image
understanding self-driving vehicles and
and more so I just started a cat image
because I wanted my talk to be popular
but so as you can see like you know this
image we have like you know more than
one layer and that's what it is
all those transformations are a bunch of
linear transformations which are overlap
across multiple layers so as you can set
that's what deep learning is mostly
about now if we forget about any
algorithm at the end of the day when it
comes to data all that we are trying to
do is Ethan else right it's all
rule-based approach what we're trying to
capture with this Ethan else is
basically some patterns now let's take a
step back and think that if it's an
image how many if and else too will we
have to actually write to actually
capture any pattern out in that image
Savior trying to identify a cat or a dog
so let's do a small experiment and let's
see if we can make it interactive what
we're trying to do here is what if we
have a pattern which is like a cross or
an X and say the computer is able to
understand that that particular pattern
of visual representation in some
numerical format so minus one one is how
I'm representing it here so if you could
see the boxes which are colored in blue
and Marcus minus one is the you know
this title and the other one is the
forward diagonals
who backward in the forward I ignore
right so let's see if we can do
something to identify this part so I
have some images here so in order to do
this I obviously with the concept of
like a sliding window can I see some
raise of hands
perfect so we're going to do something
similar and see how this gets maps to
gets mapped to a combinational network
so in the previous slide we had defined
a pattern with this representation now
let's see if we can do some sliding
window on this so that window which is
up created marked in green with some
plus and minuses that say assume that's
a sliding window that we have defined
which is 2 by 2 matrix because at the
end of the day we're dealing with pixels
so there would be some matrix
transformation and computation that we
have to take care of
and let's if we keep sliding that window
what we are trying to capture is to
learn some parting through this sliding
window so what do I mean by that so now
if if you look on the the top left
corner when we slide this window let's
assume that we had defined some
transformation rule in this case what we
are saying is that this sliding window
has plus minus minus plus matrix defined
and each time it sees a value it going
up is going to multiply that value with
it with 1 and if it's a minus 1 then
it's going to multiply it with minus 1
and then we sum all the values together
to get some numerical value out of it
and then what we can do is we can set it
special and say that if it is greater
than 0 it's a like you know it's some
sort of a diagram and the pattern that I
want to learn should be as how the
matrix the matrix you know turns up so
like in this case you see that you know
for the backward diagonals we have 4 & 4
& 4 diagonally opposite each other in
some form then if we apply the same one
with a different filter that is minus
plus plus minus if you see I've just
transposed the design set then I can
just reverse it and mirror it as a
forward diagonals so now what I've done
is but just by defining a simple filter
what I've tried to catch
is that I'm trying to identify some
pattern from the image so now that the
filter is typically called what what how
we define convolution as so that's what
we say like you know convolution layer
is typically that's what it is doing now
the activation function is some you know
some sexual function that we have kind
of defined based on which it will
activate some neurons and it will
deactivate sumner all so basically it's
in this case it will highlight for in
for an odd - or we could say severe site
official or greater than zero and with
that what we've done is we have
identified the pattern that we are
looking for and towards the end so there
is something else called as polling
layer and polling layer is basically as
subsampling because we are dealing with
millions of pixel data points so it's
computationally very expensive so there
may be some way where we can shrink the
size of the image so that we can start
focusing on some certain aspects of the
image so I just mentioned about
convolutional layer which is basically
just think in terms of a filter that
we're going to define and sliding window
so we keep moving it it could be one
pixel to pixel to pixel or three pixels
as to how we want to make the window
move then we define an activation
function and then we also defined up a
polling there towards the end what we do
is we say it's a fully connected layer
when we connect all the neurons together
take all the weights that has been
associated with each other and
superimpose the different learning a
different learning list and then we get
the final image so what we have done is
we started with a simple use case and we
apply the filter and we have identified
our passenger so with that let's define
what a convolutional neural network is
so convolutional neural network is a
type of feed-forward artificial neural
network so it moves in the forward
direction that's what it means with
respect to feed-forward so there is no
back cycle which is there we can set a
back propagation but typically when we
think of
we are thinking in terms of feed-forward
so it's always moving in a forward
direction and they have been proven very
successful with respect to pattern
recognition with respect to images there
are three key properties when it comes
to convolutional neural network one is
the spatial arrangement so what happens
is that in each layer we define neurons
we have to kind of define some some sort
of a dimension to capture this the image
representation as a matrix so we define
that matrix as height width height and
depth depth is to capture the different
color channels in simple terms if we
think of three then it's this RGB so red
green and blue and they could be multi
like you know they could be more than
three channels or depending on us - how
many was the depth that we want to cover
and this depth is one of the type of
parameters that we can click on to get
more and more refined images or better
classifications then there's something
called as local connectivity so what
happens is that H you see the red box
there this we have the heat the big red
box and then a smaller one so that is so
that is like so that is one neuron which
is capturing a certain aspect of the
image and that is being transformed to a
set of values and all those values they
are so they are sensitive only to that
specific location
small region and all of those the
neurons in that block so let me let me
put this way the filter that we had
defined earlier the green box that is
like one neuron that we ate the small
region that we are talking about and
that small box will have the same weight
for all the other values in that in that
box so that's what we mean by the shades
weight so all the neurons for a given
convolutional net will respond to the
same feature weights and then the you
know the the rest of the the diagram is
just showing an activation function
which which there are like multiple
different activation
functions which are defined simple ones
could be like sigmoid and tarnish and
then there are like multiple others so
with that let's take a brief look into
how a convolution convolutional neural
network architecture typically typically
looks like so we have an image that's we
can define our sets an image of the
robot here and we define this green box
as a small filter we filter across the
whole image we keep sliding the window
or the filter across the whole image we
capture certain values so what it is
doing is capturing certain aspects of
the of the image and what and transforms
into multiple layers of feature Maps
this feature Maps that we start like we
keep increasing the depth of this filter
so and with the pooling which is
basically subsampling we keep reducing
the size of the image that we're looking
at so what happens is that as we move
from higher to a lower layer higher
layers will have it will have like the
true representation of the whole image
and as we start moving towards the lower
layer it will be start it will start to
focus on more specific elements of the
of a particular image I have a better
slide that I can walk you guys through
so with that let's take a liking a
change of topic so let's talk a little
bit about tensor flow so we all know
it's great for deep learning
obviously released by Google can be used
for general purpose numerical
computation on the core is written in
C++ which helps in faster computation
specially especially with respect to
matrix multiplication it has fun trait
front ends in Python and C++ which makes
it easier for a lot of us to quickly
experiment and play around with it so in
this side what I've done is just just
you know trying to capture a very simple
numeric computation using tensor flow so
in this what all I'm trying to do is
just multiply
- numeric values and then get an output
one thing that you guys would know is
that I'm statically mentioning the type
of the variables that that I'm asking
the tensorflow to take in and do the
multiplication which helps in faster
computation and this graph that I'm
trying to show here is basically
articulating the fact that in the
tensorflow world everything is a data
flow graph so we deal with all numerical
computations as some as a graph data
flow they yeah so now let's do another
change of topic and talk about livvie
and spock magic
so as the the whole space around Spock
has become so popular that maintaining
clusters is becoming really difficult
especially like you know in an
enterprise dev environment people have
to constantly change their cluster type
and you know maybe today is clouded or
tomorrow is hot and works
a month later maybe it's map R and so on
and so forth and it's becoming really
difficult for for enterprises to
maintain that their environment so
recently there is a project called Leiby
which which got open sourced and
basically what it does is it allows us
to connect to spark clusters using a
test interface so basically what we're
doing now is instead of connecting Manly
to a spark cluster we have a rest
interface where we can define some
functions and invoke some web books to
to a spark cluster and then we can
launch a jobs there are some other cool
features around it we can have multiple
spark context we can share the rdd's or
the data frames that we are creating
across multiple jobs and finds have is
everyone in the room has got a chance to
play around with sparkles familiar when
I say what what is an RDD or a data
frame
okay so for the others rdd's and data
frames you can think of it as a numpy
array or a panda's data frame and people
familiar with that sure so think of it
like a panda's data frame and has this
some object structure that is defined to
it that it can distribute not with
respect to a single box but it could
distribute across multiple boxes and it
has the capability that if the
transformation does not go through then
you know it's going to give you error
results so it is fault tolerance or to
its weight it's like you know it's
responsible in that way so if you are
doing some computation across multiple
multiple nodes if the transformation
does not go through then it's going to
give an error response back or try to
figure out if it can please start the
whole transformation again this becomes
really useful if you are doing or
handling huge amounts of data so that's
what I mean by the RDD and data frames
this data frame is just new format for
RDD and they also through the levee rest
interface one could also submit jars
which are pre pre compiled jars snippets
of code it doesn't matter whether it is
java scala and through a client api and
spock magic is that client API so spark
magic is the jupiter kernel which allows
one to so you see this diagram so when I
mention client so that spark magic think
of it as a as a kernel for now to which
we will connect to a rest interface
which is the rest server there is the
levee server which will help us in
launching jobs into the cluster and what
I show here is a typical environment for
a spark cluster where the concept is
that we have a master node and a
multiple worker nodes so this is what I
was coming to spark magic is a simple
Jupiter kernel through which what we do
is we make a call to the livvie server
through a rest interface this is the job
X is equal
to Y is equal to X 1 plus X 2 asks Libby
to take the job and make a credit with
the sparklers to run the job get the
result and push the result back to the
two declined kernel in form of text or
adjacent as a JSON or a text format cool
all right
so we are we're done with all the boring
stuff now the cool part so now let's
start to paint right so what are we
exactly doing so in style transfer it's
a it's a fairly simple algorithm that is
there in place what we do is we take an
input image we take a style image we
extract the content from the input image
we extract the contents from the style
image and we figure out a way of merging
the two contents together superimposing
and then we create a new image now the
key or the most difficult part is
controlling that merging aspect and the
other aspect is the different features
that we are extracting form from the
content and from the style so from the
content what we do is we extract we
extract the Felicity I think if I
remember so we extract the lower-level
feature so what we want to capture it's
just the true representation of the
image we don't want the exact pixel
representation of it because we want to
change it but with style we want the
exact pixel pixel representation because
we want to up superimpose that
representation on top of the actual
image to generate a new image so on the
surface at a high level that's what
there is to the algorithm and how do we
do it so that let me introduce something
called as vgg 90 has anyone heard of her
cool so you guys know that it got
created out of the image net challenge
that was there I think back in 2014 and
Karen and Andrew were the people who
designed this VG 19 that it's you know
it's trained over a million images to
classify thousand objects so it's like a
rich data
and typically it can detect almost all
forms of common objects that we could
think of and it's very powerful so
that's what I mean by capable of
recognizing feature representations of
wide range of images why is it 19
systems it is composed of 16 so we're
talking about deep neural network so
obviously a lot of layers which has 16
convolutional s it has 16 different
filters it has 5 so I mentioned that max
pooling so this pooling when we are
trying to down sample down something
could be done in different ways we could
think of it like if we have a set of
values and one wants to and one is given
a task that give me one value if I give
you five values just return me one now
that one value could be an average of
those five values it could be a max of
those five values it could be minimum
typically for pooling people use Max and
average and towards the end we have
three fully connected lists so we're
talking about a convolutional layer so
it's like from each layer we if we take
all the the weights and we transform it
to the next layer or pass it on to the
next layer so we have three fully
connected layer so that we get like a
very good image representation to Sdn so
this is how we gg 19 representation
typically looks like so as you can see
we have gone like in of those numbers
that I mentioned there those are the
different convolutional filters that
that is created as a part of each age 19
so basically it's a pre compiled a
pre-trained image image recognition
model that we're going to be using for
extracting different aspects of the
input and the style image so I was
mentioning that when we are at the below
the the the lower layers that is when we
are starting it it starting with the
extraction of the image so we are at
depths 64 and as you see that you know
as we go further down the depth is
increasing so when the depth is
increasing it is starting to focus on
the
the it is starting to focus on the the
actual structure of the image and it's
starting to forget about the exact pixel
values to soar so for example if if I
were to give you know this room it's
just going to remember like the basic
structure of it and start forgetting
about like you know whether the walls
are painted in gray and so on so what
how it becomes helpful is that when we
use so then we use the lower layers on
this tile input to extract the definer
also views the the higher layers to
extract the style input the pixel values
from the style input so that we could
get the pixel representation of the of
the image as shown here like in a small
snippet of code that we could typically
use to you know the you guys can try it
at home and see what this layers look
like so with that let's start to paint
right so what I did is I took a sketch
of the Space Needle this is a famous
painting as a silent put and I unn tried
to apply using this tile transfer
algorithm and see if I if I am able to
control the final image that I'm trying
to get so what I show those three images
that are there are intermediate
transformation steps as you can see that
the one on the on the on the Left is is
a little it's not clear what it is what
the final image is going to be because
it's in the process of superimposing the
images and as we move along towards the
end we see that oh okay so we have
generated some some cool image or two at
the end so one more quick thing so since
we're doing machine learning there needs
to be some cost function or a loss
function that we are trying to optimize
on so as we are superimposing these
different images there what is that loss
function that we are trying to optimize
on and how do we control the different
weights on it so that we have a control
on the image that is getting generated
so as mentioned earlier we are using an
input image of using a pre trained vgg
19 model to extract in this case for an
input image we use the lower layers to
extract the true representation because
this we just we just want the spatial
structured representation of the image
and for the input image we want the
exact pixel values so we use the lower
the higher layers as you can see and
then we combine the two together so
there is a little so what I've left out
is there's a small matrix computation
that is happening underneath but towards
the end all that we are trying to
optimize it on is the loss in the image
content loss in the style content and
some days something called as total
variational denoising this is basically
to to capture the effect that if an
image moves a certain distance we still
able to capture the you know the the
true representation of an open image but
the more the most important aspect is
the alpha and beta and that is the way
it related to content in the way it
related to style and as we keep
experimenting on that we will see that
we keep generating different images so
so we talked about so we have covered a
lot of different topics right we started
with defining convolutional layer then
we jumped some slides we talked about
tensor flow we talked about spark we
talked about Livy and we talked about
Spock magic so how can we combine all of
this together and how is spark and route
tensorflow helping or will help us in
any way so most of the deep learning
computation we think of this as like a
single powerful box where we you know
deploy an algorithm maybe probably use
the GPU and it computes the result but
as we know that still getting access to
the GPU clusters may not be that easily
possible or even if it is its way so the
single most important thing in obviously
I would say the second most important
thing in in training predictive or
machine learning models is hyper
parameter
tuning the first one being feature
engineering and selection right so we
try to solve that using deep learning
some automated feature learning and
selection that is happening but we are
still left with the problem that we have
to control the other parameters that are
associated with respect to deep learning
let's say is the depth in this case is
the Alpha and Beta that is the content
weight and the style weight there are
other aspects to it that we might have
to control so how can we start tuning a
lot of these start building a lot of
this small in power low so that's what I
mean by that's where its path will
really be useful for you know building
or doing hyper parametric tuning in
parallel and this is embarrassingly
parallel because there is no alternative
operation which is which is happening
when we do parameter tuning I creative
in a way that there isn't any input that
is happening in step zero that needs to
be passed into step one and this helps
tremendously in reducing the train time
the other aspect where SPARC would
really help with along with tensorflow
is with respect to deploying multiple
models so as we train a model and we
have to score large amounts of data it
helps us in distributing the whole
workflow so and you know since its fault
tolerant we don't have to like you know
we still have to worry about the
failures but we know when a failure
failure occurs so so this is this is a
legend of the typical architecture so
the one on the left is suppose we are
trying to do hyper parameter tuning
using cross-validation so what we can do
is using spark so if we have tensorflow
configured on a cluster we can launch a
job and ask the cluster to train
multiple models in parallel and to a C
and select the best model what I am
representing towards the right is how we
can use pathologic kernel through a rest
interface Libby and we connect to a
remote remote cluster where I've
configured tensorflow on the worker
nodes so so that's one thing
tensorflow binder easy to exist in all
the worker nodes and also probably in
the master if we're trying to do any
computation using tensorflow library on
the master as well but if not then the
tensorflow library just needs to be on
the mass on the worker nodes so how do
we so the next set of slides what i'm
going to talk about is how we can use
libyan spark magic to do this scalable
parameter tuning so step one would be to
get the client ready and to connect with
the spark cluster so once the the the
levy server is up one can use this part
of the spark magic kernel called a
command like configure and we can set
the parameters that we that we want our
cluster we can basically we can define
the cluster size for for a spark
clusters in this case it's like you know
we want the executors memory to be four
gigs and the codes to be to be of two
before and also so that everybody's on
the same page when I talk about these
executors to think of it like virtual
VMs that we are able to dynamically
create so then step two would be to
specify some parameters like I was
mentioning even when we are doing deep
learning this like a huge bunch of
parameters that we have to control in
this case since we are doing style
transferring a lot of the parameters are
associated with respect to weights
number of iterations as we increase in
number of iteration the loss that we are
trying to optimize on that will reduce
and then there are different weights
associated to the the content that is
the input image and the style and the
style image so and then then we kind of
define some command that we want to use
it I'm just mentioning here as a as a
command but it could be a Python
function as well or that we we can
attach to an RDD and ask it to compute
you know multiple modules in parallel
so so yes that's what is happening in
the next set of steps I'm just taking
that command and then building a
collection using these combinations that
I have mentioned here and then creating
multiple such commands Adam I will use
Park to distribute in parallel in the
question and ask you to generate
multiple images so with that let's do a
quick quiz and see if somebody could
help me give an answer to to this
question so say suppose if I have three
sets a has two values we have three
values and C has two values as well as
well so can anyone help me answer how
many number of combinations total number
of combinations are we looking at can we
have a raise of hand yes that's right so
yeah I actually have a small there for
you so just so that's the right answer
but the most important aspect is that as
we see these are a lot of modules so
then there is this other aspect of how
do we optimize this hyper parameter
tuning and they are like you know
multiple ways to do that I will say that
there is something called as random
parameter optimizer random feature
parameter selection that one could use
to to further optimize this but details
on that may be for another time so now
getting back to what we were trying to
do we are trying to do paralyze the
parameter tuning so now with SPARC what
I'm going to do is we created you know
multiple we created like 12 models or
model formats or commands so now the
next next set of tasks is to distribute
or a spark to distribute those jobs into
the cluster compute the result and then
return the result back so with for this
what I'm trying to do is I'm making use
of sub-process
from the energy of Python library
and then launching multiple external
jobs into the sparker executor
environment running the jobs and then
collecting waiting for all the jobs to
complete asynchronously and then
collecting all the results back so with
this some likes we wrote like maybe 10
or 15 lines of code what I've done is
with quickly taken this computationally
expensive image segmentation algorithm
and try to distribute it in parallel and
compute multiple models at the same time
okay so I got like a couple of sides so
so so what can we use side transfer
algorithm for so like I'm a huge fan of
deadpool and spiderman so i thought it
would be cool to see if deadpool could
be a friendly neighborhood the image is
somewhat okay I couldn't have a lot of
control on the weight there but this one
was pretty good so so this could be like
for sports content generation similarly
it could be for branding and one quick
side here this with respect to
computation so I still have to
experiment with computing a cluster
where I could which is basically a GPU
enabled spark cluster and see how much
performance gain I get but even even
with simple like you know the simple
experimentation a single computation was
taking me like an R and 4 for 12 models
that I created it took me like nine
hours so there is still some improvement
and this is very simple clusters like
one master and one worker node cluster
so it's not very like you know super
fancy cluster that I'm looking at and
that time will reduce as increase the
number of nodes so sorry we need to
follow him okay we're running out of
time
okay so let's give an applause to
premier
[Applause]